côté bd là ouais c'est vous ils sont
trois richie nos deux ans et demi annie
neuf mois et laurent 19 ans tous les
trois souffrent de malformations
cardiaques et doivent être opéré dans
les prochains jours s'ils viennent
accueillera chez elles le plus grand est
la plus petit il appelle accueillera
richie nos christian joly lui coordonne
toute l'opération pour régler ça c'est
le dos et a toujours gardé avec toi
d'accord il ya sans passeport question
jolie et le président de la ribambelle
une chaîne de solidarité présente en
france depuis 21 ans et à la réunion
depuis l'année dernière il n'y a pas de
temps à perdre
mais leur arrivée laurent ricci nos et
annie ont rendez vous au chu de belles
pierres
elle est où l'on a tous droit richie nos
sera le premier au perdant -2 48
allez on y va on va l'installer le
docteur celi est cardiologue bien
regarder petit coeur de la télé d'accord
peut-être un petit peu froid comme étant
ben gaudin dans le coeur de richie nos
il y à ce qu'on appelle en terme médical
une des licences une ouverture à normale
entre les deux ventricules ici le fond
rouge qu'on voit normalement ici la
paroisse de communication et dans aucun
frais qui passe une fuite que l'équipe
de cardiologie infantile du chu va
réparer
c'est le docteur dubois qui pratiquera
l'opération mais tin oo je sais que je
t'explique ton opération qui on va
ouvrir ici de rang comme ça on va voir
le coeur lignac et pour fermer le petit
trou on va mettre un petit patch
on va ainsi tirer avec des files sans
cette opération impossible à madagascar
richie nos aurait risqué de graves
problèmes cardiaques pendant toute sa
vie contre la maison dans les länder
dans quelques jours il pourra rêver
d'une fille comme tous les autres
enfants
la nuit est déjà tombée depuis longtemps
sur saint-pierre qu'henri chino arrive
chez isabelle amont vers les bas
stéfane ricci nos partis le matin
d'antananarive il a déjà derrière lui
sacrée journée mais il a l'air en pleine
forme
viens on va voir où tu dors mémoire je
te montre ma maison ok avec vous dans ce
village là et imaginer que dans deux
jours il venait voir opération à coeur
ouvert
oui je vais est inquiète g je pense que
je vais être comme comme si c'était un
de mes fils qui se fait opérer quoi une
opération si grave quand même à son âge
eux d'ouvrir la pas facile mercredi 6
heures du matin c'est le jour de
l'opération et richie nos est déjà là
il avait il a fallu les veillées à
quelle heure ce matin il est au calme
avant pour les opérations du coeur on
envoyait les enfants malgaches se faire
opérer à marseille aujourd'hui la
création d'un service de cardiologie
infantile à la réunion permet de
raccourcir les distances et d'accueillir
les enfants dans un environnement plus
familier mais qui grimpe qui grimpe
grimpe à la réunion c'est un petit peu
mada quand même ça y'a rien qui les
choque ici ils sont pas inquiets qu'ils
soient pas stressés départ pour le
bloqueur richie noé maintenant mener
vers le bloc opératoire
je suis là mais oui tati et la complète
le petit garçon a l'air de se demander
ce qui va lui arriver
il est 8 heures l'intervention va
débuter dans un instant et hino
quand nous sommes d'autoriser à pénétrer
dans la salle d'opération le docteur
dubois déjà le coeur de richie nos entre
les mains et toute une équipe s'affaire
autour de l'enfant
l'opération a commencé depuis une heure
le chirurgien à pratiquer une incision
de 10 centimètres dans la poitrine de
l'enfant puis il a écarté les codes pour
accéder au coeur pas plus gros qu'une
pêche sur l'écran de contrôle
on le voit battre encore mais il va
bientôt s'arrêter
on peut dessiner ventriculaire ils sont
branchés pour pouvoir opérer le coeur
est mise à l'arrêt via les cas nul placé
par le chirurgien le sang est alors
dériver vers sète machin qui pendant
toute l'opération va remplacer le coeur
avec une extrême précision le chirurgien
ouvre le coeur et accède à l'endroit où
un passage anormale a été détectée entre
les deux ventricules de longues minutes
s'écoulent dans une totale concentration
puis le chirurgien dispose ce petit
patch blanc pour qu'il n'y ait plus de
passage entre les deux hommes
l'intervention s'achève le coeur peut
être réactivé
on peut commencer à effectivement
l'opération a duré quatre heures
il ne reste plus qu à recoudre les
parois de l'abdomen
l'anesthésiste peut à présent retiré le
champ qui protégeait la zone d'opération
le visage du petit richie nos encore
profondément endormi a paraît il ne se
réveillera que le lendemain
l'opération s'est bien passée
l'opération s'est très bien déroulé
l'écart a été bien protégé il est
reparti tout seul et voilà nous avons
plus le sevrer delà de la machine coeur
poumon artificiel
donc là il circule tout seul il est à
bonne température et ils respirent tout
seuls
si on ne l'avait pas opérée qu'est ce
qui se serait passé les prochaines
années qu'il aurait été d'abord dans son
enfance limité on est par contre exemple
il peut pas faire du sport comme tous
les enfants de son âge
et puis offert au fur et à mesure ses
capacités physiques vont diminuer et
donc ils ne pourraient pas suivre des
cours parce qu'il serait très fatigué je
veux pas prédire exactement mais il
aurait eu des graves soucis dans la fin
de l'adolescence et l'âge adulte jeunes
entre eux on va dire entre 15 ans et 30
ans quarante huit heures plus tard nous
retrouvons richie nous dans le service
des soins intensifs
les nouvelles sont bonnes la cicatrice
évolue bien
mary chino est encore à faible là c'est
sous sédatifs pour éviter les douleurs
il ne tarde d'ailleurs pas se rendormir
il dort là il faudra attendre encore
deux jours pour retrouver le petit
bonhomme plein de vie enfin voilà parés
pour le retour dimanche soir
ça y est richie noda nouveau sur pied
prête à quitter l'hôpital
la rétine on va montrer que les
pansements que le docteur tu as remis et
dans deux jours s'il tourne le docteur
m'a dit que c'était pas grave c'est
réparé alors on rit chino demande alors
à isabelle la photo ranger dans la
poussette
ces visas aux mamans lé moulaert la
maman et mamie
[Rires]
ça y est en garde à vue on sort richie
ne retrouvera sa famille dans quelques
semaines après sa convalescence chez
isabelle et stéphane on reviendra juste
pour montrer aux deux paires la
cicatrice l'année prochaine la
ribambelle voudrait accueillir trente
enfants malgaches pour des opérations du
coeur à la réunion
[Musique]